let's go to our next caller from the 602
area code caller from 602 you're on can
you hear me
yeah go ahead okay
David how worried are you about future
election tampering be it by hacking by
another country or person or by our own
elected officials using even more voter
suppression tactics like we saw in
Arizona in 2016 with the post the
placement of the voter booths was
directly going to effect the impact or
the way that the votes the way that the
election turned out is what I'm trying
very very elections which would be very
important in a post Trump world yeah I'm
extraordinarily worried because you now
have you have election tampering that
can happen on multiple fronts right
you've got the possibility of hacking
voting machines which has been covered
for years at this point you've got the
possibility of foreign meddling which by
the way Robert Mulder says Russia is
actively meddling in the midterm
elections right now already you also
then have voter suppression tactics
right strategic limiting of voting hours
voter ID requirements for IDs that might
themselves be free but in order to
obtain them you need other documents
which are not free to obtain for example
so there is like a three-pronged attack
on election integrity that's going on
right now Donald Trump doesn't seem even
remotely concerned about it that voter
integrity commission was disbanded and
was only even there to try to find
evidence of 3 to 5 million illegal votes
for Hillary Clinton it was it was never
really going to deal with the issues
that we were facing
so I'm massively worried about it I
would agree with you yeah and
unfortunately this is one of those
issues where we try to talk about it
year-round not just like the month
before the election but it's one of
those issues that starts to get traction
when it's mostly too late to do anything
about it sadly right the only time you
could actually do something like
implement rank-choice voting or
change the system in any sort of
legitimate way is probably not right
before right after an election when
everybody's the most upset about it yeah
although in a sense it's always either
closely before or closely after an
election and that's part of the problem
as well I mean it's just it's it's a
really bad situation really appreciate
the call important yeah okay very good
yes so he hung up before I did he was
sick of me before I decided to move on